foreign
[Music]
thank you
it's not quite cool
[Music]
ers
congratulations
foreign
[Music]
all right
excited
[Applause]
welcome
faculty colleagues families
friends and most importantly welcome
class of 2023.
[Applause]
I'm Lynn Cooley I have the honor of
being the dean of The Graduate School
I'm joined on stage and on the front
rows by members of the Dean's office The
Faculty who are here to represent all
the support and mentoring you've
received while at Yale
it's a pleasure to welcome everyone
who's here in Woolsey and who's joining
us online to celebrate with our
graduates
not too loud
you have been an integral part of one of
civilization's highest inventions the
research University where the mission is
the creation and dissemination of new
knowledge across Generations
as you've learned during your time at
Yale discovering new knowledge and
revealing the truth about our world is
not a solitary endeavor
you have lived within an extensive
academic Network in which you can follow
your curiosity rigorously test your
ideas benefit from critique and go
forward in an unexpected Direction
you have learned that a convincing
argument backed by evidence from primary
sources or well-controlled experiments
will stand up to careful scrutiny and
importantly pave the way for the next
person to take another step
Savor this rejoice in this it is a rare
privilege to possess this experience and
its teaching can can be applied
throughout your life
each year at matriculation where we
welcome the incoming class of graduate
students I emphasize that graduate
school is very much about getting
comfortable with uncertainty and
dwelling at the edge of the unknown
I hope that this journey has been full
of excitement and surprises that have
led you to where you are today
while this endeavor can be quite
daunting when you begin and perhaps at a
few moments along the way you can now
stand proud of your accomplishments
celebrate your success and look forward
to the next exciting chapter
today you leave Yale as thinkers
explorers creators teachers and you also
leave with a set of skills that equip
you for a variety of careers
you are Innovative and critical thinkers
problem solvers leaders team players and
effective communicators
whatever Direction you choose to apply
your skills of advanced learning let
your accomplishments here inspire you to
tackle new challenges with the
confidence that your time in graduate
school has prepared you for any obstacle
that may lie ahead
every moment in the attempt to bring
light to truth
depends on our collaborations and
relationships with others
the commitment of time effort and
attention required to achieve an
advanced degree is only possible with
the participation and support of
professors mentors classmates
collaborators and also our families and
friends
these are the people we turn to when
things go wrong and also the people we
turn to to celebrate occasions like this
when we thrive
you have been supported by many people
on campus whose labor and loyalty
contribute every day to Yale
and make it the distinguished University
it is
let's let me take a moment to name
several of the groups of Yale staff
Beyond The Faculty represented here on
stage who stand at the heart of Yale and
then we can thank them together
the University's custodial and
maintenance staff who make Yale
beautiful every day
the clerical and Technical staff who
support all our work
the managerial and professional staff
who administer our departments and
schools
and specifically the staff of The
Graduate School of Arts and Sciences who
sustained the institution within which
within which graduate education thrives
at Yale let's thank all these wonderful
individuals
finally
and separately I also want to
acknowledge the superb musical abilities
of our organist Mr Colin Miller one of
our many accomplished students in the
Institute of Sacred Music who is playing
on one of the world's great pipe organs
in Woolsey Hall Colin
you have relied on the people we just
applauded and many many others I hope
that during your time at Yale you have
cultivated lifelong friendships with
both your peers and your mentors
these relationships will continue to
sustain you on whatever path life takes
next
to this day I remain in touch with my
own graduate Mentor who will retire from
Yale this year after 56 years on our
faculty
I worked in his lab as a graduate
student he changed my life forever as he
did for countless others
I've now also built lifelong
relationships with my own graduate
students who have gone on to successful
careers as faculty in industry and in
medicine
this company of Scholars and Society of
friends as the former Yale president G W
Pearson once called it is a gift that
Yale imparts to its students and I hope
that you cherish it for the many years
to come
to that end let us also acknowledge the
contributions of the many faculty
sitting with us today as well as those
who are not here who have supported you
throughout graduate school
graduates it has been my privilege to be
your dean and Lead The Graduate school's
efforts to provide you with the
environment in which you have grown into
the scholars you are today
graduate study takes inspiration but
also hard work and especially
perseverance and determination learning
to continue in the face of challenges
characterizes the ability to do Advanced
research and the fact that you sit here
today means you have learned that lesson
you have overcome all of the obstacles
that stood in your way including a
global pandemic and completed your
studies in Triumph I'm proud of all that
you have accomplished and excited to see
what you will do next congratulations
we will now award graduate degrees we
will call the graduates to the stage
alphabetically by the department or
program in which they've earned their
degrees
Dean's Michelle niron and Sarah Inslee
will read each name please come forward
as your name is called I also invite
faculty here with us to come up into the
front of the stage as their department
or program is called and join me in
congratulating all of their degree
recipients and yes please applaud and
cheer as you see fit remember today is
about an important Milestone and
transition to a new life phase
celebrated
[Applause]
for the program in African studies
for the degree of master of arts
Brad Brockman
[Applause]
Sarah Adele Daly
for the program in American studies
for the degree of doctor of philosophy
FEI Wang
for the program in anthropology
for the degree of doctor of philosophy
Nicholas Edward Brown
[Applause]
Carly Chaney
Amanda Christy lease
[Music]
[Applause]
rudong ning
for the program in applied physics
for the degree of doctor of philosophy
couldn't Duke Kim
[Applause]
Wong
for the degree of master of science
for the program in archaeological
studies
for the degree of master of arts
Samantha Haley Brown
[Music]
[Applause]
Hayes IV
uwei Li
[Applause]
a rose Siebert
Christopher Scott Wilson
for the program in astronomy
for the degree of doctor of philosophy
[Applause]
Samuel Harris Connors Cabot
for the program in cell biology
for the degree of doctor of philosophy
Augustine Horace
[Applause]
Lucas Allen Fuentes
Andres Gian saman
[Applause]
zaoping Hong
Patrice swen
[Applause]
for the program in cellular and
molecular physiology
for the degree of doctor of philosophy
[Applause]
Ki Wang
for the program in chemistry
for the degree of doctor of philosophy
alpala Chaudhary
[Applause]
[Music]
suyan Choi
[Applause]
Laura Faye Cotter
Daniel dimitrisku
[Applause]
Jessica Jean Caitlyn freeze
Noreen Elizabeth Gentry
[Applause]
Abigail Hoyer
[Music]
[Applause]
Kevin Hong
Ian shu
[Music]
[Applause]
Tian cool
osong Juan
[Applause]
Anton lachowitz
Juan on Liu
[Applause]
Alexandra Lauren nagalik nagelski
Sarah Courtney ostrich
[Applause]
Maxim Alton sakur
season Shen
[Applause]
Andrew Douglas stripe
Santino James stroupoli
[Applause]
Oriel Tava
[Music]
Jaleesa Torres Robles
[Applause]
Tanya Maria Townsend
Jennifer troiano
[Applause]
now Dean van der hoovel
Jeremy Evan Weber
[Applause]
Connor Van Wilson
in tran Drew
[Applause]
for the program in classics
for the degree of doctor of philosophy
Christopher John Landa
[Applause]
Joseph Railton Morgan II
for the program in comparative
literature
for the degree of doctor of philosophy
lital abazon
[Applause]
for the program in computational biology
and bioinformatics
for the degree of doctor of philosophy
[Music]
Daniel shablal shavla
[Applause]
for the program in computer science
[Music]
[Applause]
for the degree of doctor of philosophy
Jake Brower
[Applause]
who
ning luo
[Applause]
there you Wong
yaluzang
[Applause]
for the degree of master of science
[Music]
[Applause]
you do
yingji agu
[Applause]
zayugu
[Music]
[Applause]
baishi how
Yan he
[Applause]
[Music]
is
[Applause]
sikhili
Shang long Lee
[Applause]
in ruling
yutong Liao
[Applause]
Charlotte Megan long
Enoch Amelie
[Applause]
[Music]
hean glue Peng
[Applause]
Sian pool
rui Shen
[Applause]
guano ISU
kaiwan soon
[Applause]
Hui Wang
care Wang
[Applause]
Ray Wong
Xiang Wang
[Applause]
SI sang
Alexander Luis Michael M Wardle Solano
Shin yuei shoe
[Applause]
issue on shoe
Ebola Yan
[Applause]
Edward yang
[Music]
[Applause]
meow you yang
lingui Zhang
[Applause]
Yan Chong
Zhang
[Applause]
yuei Zhang
using Zhang
[Applause]
wine
for the program in Earth and planetary
Sciences
for the degree of doctor of philosophy
Michael Hansen
[Applause]
Ula hide
bulgiana Calderon
[Applause]
Ryan Lee
you Liang
[Applause]
Sophie westicott
for the program in East Asian languages
and literatures
for the degree of doctor of philosophy
bow on
[Applause]
Nina farazova
[Music]
Lauren David Waller
[Applause]
D Hao Chow
[Music]
[Applause]
for the program in East Asian studies
for the degree of master of arts
wailing Fung
[Applause]
SI Juan Jiang
Ray yen
[Music]
[Applause]
da Lin
kaijao Liu
[Applause]
Andrew
Aika Sato
[Applause]
Candace Joy Snowden
when Ray Tai
[Music]
[Applause]
anshi Yan
CeCe yang
[Applause]
shinyu Zhang
[Music]
zeylon ciao
[Applause]
for the program in ecology and
evolutionary biology
for the degree of doctor of philosophy
Chang Yu Chang
[Applause]
for the program in economics
for the degree of doctor of philosophy
Shanghai
Zara contractor
[Applause]
Lucas Johan Edward Conwell
will Stetson Dameron
[Music]
[Applause]
Lucas Fenimore
David Galvez Alvarez
[Applause]
on her
barrage Rajiv jorapore
[Applause]
[Music]
Sangre Kim
[Applause]
Angelo criazis
[Music]
[Applause]
masaki miyashita
Antonio Paredes has
Jin take song
[Applause]
Michael Roland Sullivan
joao Paulo Valente
[Applause]
[Music]
Trevor Colton Williams
[Applause]
Diana zoo
[Music]
[Applause]
in engineering and applied science
for the program in biomedical
engineering
for the degree of doctor of philosophy
Catherine Helen Bridges
[Applause]
Rebecca Wright Byler
David de la
[Applause]
Fay Mei Liu
Ryan young Newman
[Applause]
David Mark O'Connor
[Music]
Kevin tonta
[Applause]
Yuki Wong
Liang yang
for the degree of master of science
benani
[Applause]
umod Bole
Blake bowels
[Applause]
Tahir dim Melo
fun
[Applause]
ding Hao Wu
choosy John
[Applause]
[Music]
for the program in chemical and
environmental engineering
for the degree of doctor of philosophy
you how do
[Applause]
Ryan deschanwa
swearer Hussein
[Applause]
Nina Yankovic
Eric Philip Johnson
[Applause]
Cody Rhett
thank you
Julianne Naomi Rolfe
[Applause]
seshwen you
Junction Drew
for the degree of master of science
oyan akif
[Applause]
de Lindsay Damas
[Music]
for the program in electrical
engineering
for the degree of doctor of philosophy
kazra esfandiari
[Applause]
way Foo
yuang Jiang
[Applause]
Jonathan Daniel cause
Bing John Lee
Nicholas papadis
[Applause]
ayed al-sayam
Shan Shuan Tien
Ming rui
[Music]
[Applause]
Rodman Evans Lambert
for the program in mechanical
engineering and Material Science
for the degree of doctor of philosophy
Robert Lawrence Baines
[Applause]
[Music]
Trevor Luke Buckner
[Applause]
David James heenick
[Music]
[Applause]
Andrew Scott Morgan
[Music]
[Applause]
Aya nawano
Luis Javier Perez Lorenzo
[Applause]
suray Reed Lingenfelter
Lee hen Zhang
[Applause]
for the degree of master of science
Christian H black
[Music]
[Applause]
Charles Christopher Weir
for the program in personalized medicine
and applied engineering for the degree
of master of science
Ashley vinaya Anthony
Crystal Chung
[Applause]
Derek demel
Eric David Elfman
Alice Huang
Kendall toy
for the program in English language and
literature
for the degree of doctor of philosophy
Peter Conroy
Anna Aurora Hill
Trina he Jung
[Music]
[Applause]
Margaret Ann McGowan
Benjamin Polk Ross
[Applause]
[Music]
Xiao Schwann 2
for the program and environment
for the degree of doctor of philosophy
sintra AG
[Applause]
Hare Krishna venu gopalan nayar Radha
money
foreign
in European and Russian studies for the
degree of master of arts
Carrie Elizabeth Selden dealer
Murad bondlik
[Music]
[Applause]
Carolyn Stephanie Dunbar
[Music]
[Applause]
Holly Lauren Harris
Vanessa maderova
[Applause]
Maximus milta
yevendi monastrovsky
[Applause]
for the program in experimental
pathology
for the degree of doctor of philosophy
Garrett Arlington
[Applause]
Luke batty
Christopher Joshua Minter
[Applause]
Jonathan's son
for the program in film and media
studies
for the degree of doctor of philosophy
Juan Pang
[Applause]
for the program in French
for the degree of doctor of philosophy
Sophia Halverson
[Applause]
Aaron Richard Kessel
Hannah razel Roberts cowsman
Madison Brent Maine Waring
for the program in genetics
for the degree of doctor of philosophy
Alec Barrett
Cecilia Harold
[Applause]
mengwei who
Acadia Coker
[Applause]
meow Liu
Dennis Paul May the Third
[Applause]
Jessica Lisa Moore
Elias quinoa
[Applause]
young way
Christina Yim
[Music]
[Applause]
for the program in history
for the degree of doctor of philosophy
Aziz
[Applause]
saloni Bauman
Henry Atticus Clements
[Applause]
Marius cother
AP Krishna nodi
[Applause]
call Ross rice II
Rachel Elizabeth Rosenberg
[Applause]
[Music]
ishin Talon kakmak
[Applause]
Monique Flores Ulysses
[Music]
[Applause]
Tiana Williams
for the degree of master of arts
Gracie Anderson
Joseph Edwards
[Applause]
James Benjamin Flynn
[Music]
Samuel Ralph Turner
[Applause]
for the program in history of art for
the degree of doctor of philosophy
Chelsea Alice Connelly
[Applause]
Sophia gunnersdotir
a
[Applause]
Lucy Rose Hunter
Eric Jonathan Kessel Jr
[Applause]
Cynthia Coke
Sarah Anna Seligman
[Music]
Judith Stapleton
[Applause]
Stephen Tyler yurchik
for the program in history of science
and medicine for the degree of doctor of
philosophy
Megan Elizabeth Ford lishka
[Applause]
Sarah Mendoza Pikman
Maya Corey Sandler
[Applause]
Simon Joseph torresenta
for the program in immunobiology for the
degree of doctor of philosophy
Molly Lynn Buckland
Emily k condiv
[Music]
[Applause]
Lindsey Demery Hughes
Kavita is Ronnie Winger
Tian Yong Mao
[Applause]
when's the song
Paris to yagubi
[Applause]
Young
in the interdepartmental Neuroscience
program for the degree of doctor of
philosophy
sachira thenagama gay
Michael Charles farrugia
[Applause]
Leah Macy Fleming
Danielle Goldman
[Music]
[Applause]
Ankita Anand gumaste
[Music]
sahana kribakaran
[Applause]
luo ichen
Mitchell Morton
[Music]
[Applause]
tomorrow Serene Parker
[Music]
[Applause]
Zhang
for the program in international and
development economics for the degree of
master of arts
ajayi
[Music]
Sean Louise Chang
[Applause]
Ed
Fatima
yunjing Clara Huang
Abdullah
[Applause]
maithili vikas Campbell
himanish Kantipur
[Applause]
Zia young Lu
anchwan Ma
[Applause]
witty muheshwari
kavya manocha
[Applause]
ayush my Thor
namia meshram
Yuen mock
[Applause]
[Music]
garima Nan
Romel Pandey
[Applause]
Alex Phillip
[Music]
Miranda morong Q
[Applause]
OTA
Samia singla
[Applause]
Chelsea song
Krishnan
[Applause]
akashdeep Singh upal
[Music]
Yi hansu
[Applause]
Zhao
for the program in investigative
medicine for the degree of doctor of
philosophy
Vesta
Elise
[Music]
[Applause]
basil J
[Music]
[Applause]
long Huang two
for the program in Italian Studies for
the degree of doctoral philosophy
Sarah Atkinson
[Applause]
for the program in linguistics for the
degree of doctoral philosophy
Sophie Howe
[Applause]
for the program in management for the
degree of doctor of philosophy
dhruv Chand Agarwal
[Applause]
Michael Ryan Blair
Alexandra Bray
[Applause]
Leandro de Miranda Gomez
Alexander gold Clank Fulmer
[Applause]
[Music]
Jin Myung Kim
[Applause]
Juan
Yushi
[Applause]
Ankit sasodia
Brittany Ray Torres
kaushik visudevan
[Applause]
Ian Nicholas Weaver
for the program in mathematics for the
degree of doctor of philosophy
Elijah Fromm
[Music]
[Applause]
Tal malinovic
for the program in medieval studies for
the degree of doctor of philosophy
Alexander Luis Pena
[Applause]
Chihiro La Lisa tsukamoto
Clara Jane Wilde
[Music]
for the program in microbiology for the
degree of doctor of philosophy
Maya Joy Baskerville
[Applause]
Amy Teresa anti
[Music]
con Shen
thank you
for the program in molecular biophysics
and biochemistry for the degree of
doctor of philosophy
Carolyn Elaine breckel
[Applause]
Carson Jerome Bryant
Peter James Dahl
[Music]
Caroline Marguerite vote
[Applause]
Sean Dean Gray
Mason McCool
[Music]
Shivali Patel
Sarah Margaret prophet
[Applause]
Aldo Ivan Salazar Morales
Catherine Cerise ships
[Applause]
for the program in molecular cellular
and developmental biology for the degree
of doctor of philosophy
ukrajita Balaji
[Applause]
Lauren Elise Dickinson
Huang
Olivia Gail Justin
[Music]
[Applause]
Adrian Bijan Meritage
Felix Radford
[Applause]
Rocio del Mar sobetro Pena
way
[Music]
[Applause]
for the program in music for the degree
of doctor of philosophy
Henry Brian Baum
[Applause]
Tatiana Rose DOB coike
miklosh Alexander vespremi
[Applause]
for the degree of master of arts
Katy Davison
Alex Michael Whittington
[Applause]
for the program in near Eastern
languages and Civilizations for the
degree of doctor of philosophy
Jonathan David beltz Jr
[Applause]
for the program in nursing for the
degree of doctor of philosophy
Serena Cherry Flaherty
[Music]
Yuri Huang
[Applause]
Dora land Valley
and waram
[Applause]
Alexandria Catherine Smith
for the program in Pharmacology for the
degree of doctor of philosophy
Joel Andrew Sexton
Eris Katarina van alderwerald Von
Rosenberg
[Applause]
for the program in Philosophy for the
degree of doctor of philosophy
Stephen harrop
[Applause]
for the program in physics for the
degree of doctor of philosophy
Caitlin Elizabeth Beatty
Hannah Jean Bosey
London James Cooper trundle
[Applause]
Eustis Reginald Edwards
love Chrisman
[Applause]
Lee
Kai Chang Lee
giacomos kanavini
[Applause]
volodimir sivak
oscari matanpoica Tim gran
[Applause]
akshi venkutraman
taekwon Yoon
[Applause]
for the program in political science for
the degree of doctor of philosophy
Julia Allison blackner
Sofia Louisa Rose Dawkins
[Applause]
Matthew Gabriel takasugi Demi
Alejandro Fajardo arboleda
[Applause]
Morgan Faye Galloway
Ramon garibaldo Valdez
[Applause]
Michael Adam goldfein
Daniel Alexander novik Goldstein
[Music]
[Applause]
Fahad humayun
Annabelle Grace Hutchinson
[Music]
[Applause]
dip in core
naresh
[Music]
Armando pereza
[Applause]
Clara picker
[Music]
Johannes wiedeman
[Applause]
Jennifer Wu
Hikaru yamagishi
[Music]
[Applause]
for the program in psychology for the
degree of doctor of philosophy
Alexandra Faith skilken Brown
[Music]
Carlson
[Applause]
Erica ho
Michael Anthony Lopez brow
[Applause]
rashina D Seabury
Zachary silver
Shin Young
[Applause]
for the degree of Master of philosophy
o
[Applause]
for the program in public health for the
degree of doctor of philosophy
Andrew Jake arakaki
Jillian Nicole Armstrong
[Music]
[Applause]
Lindsay true
Noel Evan Dickens
[Applause]
sappho Zoe Gilbert
Hong Yuli
Adam Christopher Vieira
[Applause]
e Wang
bohawu
[Music]
yuhan Shia
[Applause]
[Music]
Chang
you
[Applause]
for the degree of master of science
[Music]
[Applause]
Chang Fang
Evangeline Iran GAO
ephan GAO
[Applause]
how you go
Han
[Applause]
Malaysia who
when house yang
[Applause]
Li Ting KU
jiyun Lee
[Applause]
Liang
[Music]
[Applause]
yui Chan Liu
Chang Liu
[Applause]
Kao chanchui Liu
Lotus Liu
[Music]
[Applause]
ruilio
Eugene Liu
Yuni Liu
Mao
[Applause]
[Music]
yuhan MO
[Applause]
GG
ruihan chin
[Applause]
shinyuichu
an
[Applause]
minjao
Shreya single
[Applause]
Laura Sun
Chi Wang
[Applause]
Wang
way
[Applause]
roshwan Wu
young fan Xiao
[Applause]
Han shu
an shu
[Applause]
Young
Han you
you Nancy
you
[Applause]
Xiao Zhang Zhang
shoman Zhang
[Applause]
Zhang
Zhao
[Applause]
I Zhao
jingyu Joe
[Applause]
Hangzhou
to use you
[Applause]
for the program in religious studies for
the degree of doctor of philosophy
[Music]
Emily Eve amarzifkin
[Applause]
yasu andemikael
[Music]
Amber lynnae Morgan drumgle
[Applause]
[Music]
James Johnston Dunn
Cali Margaret McCauley
Sarah a Miskin
Christopher Thomas Molina West
[Applause]
[Music]
for the program in Slavic languages and
literatures for the degree of doctor of
philosophy
Ingrid nordgaard
[Applause]
for the program in sociology for the
degree of doctor of philosophy
Eric Martin Felton
[Music]
[Applause]
Adam Valen Levinson
[Music]
[Applause]
for the program and statistics and data
science for the degree of doctor of
philosophy
Brandon C way Chow
[Applause]
B.J keswani
Zhang
for the degree of master of arts
Jessica Lara eschenbaugh
[Music]
[Applause]
for the degree of master of science
Daria babrova
[Applause]
Siddhartha Chatterjee
Louis Charles A descoutre
[Applause]
AU
Dan aladdison
[Applause]
katako
IFA new
Elisa Marie Lloyd
[Music]
luo
[Applause]
[Music]
Tiernan rescind me
[Applause]
Lin Zhu
we need to do the people who are late
[Applause]
every year for various reasons it
happens that some students are not able
to sit with their departments and come
forward for their diplomas in the usual
order so now we award the final degrees
which in some cases may not appear in
the program
for the degree of master of science in
the program in chemistry Elizabeth
gallmeyer
do I give him anything
for the degree of master of arts in
statistics Thomas Lockwood
[Music]
[Applause]
for the degree of master of science in
computer science Alex Lee
[Applause]
for the degree of master of arts in
African studies Esther mangangi
thank you
okay
that was something above 500 diplomas I
hope we got to the right people
huh
so next I'll ask all our degree
recipients to stand and remain standing
as we congratulate you collectively on
your impressive achievements
okay now don't sit down yet stay
standing please
at the beginning of this ceremony we
thanked many individuals for supporting
you through graduate school
graduates I'd like you to turn now find
your family and friends gathered around
you let's acknowledge the important role
they played in your achievements with a
round of applause for them
thank you
okay just a few notes please remain
standing until the platform party
recesses from the auditorium
then all of you please process out the
side exits
so either way
onto College Street or by Nicki Plaza
please do not exit through the Rotunda
because the School of Public Health is
coming in right after us and they're
going to be processing in that way
so as soon as the stage clears go to the
sides graduates you your friends and
family together with the faculty and
staff who are here with us are invited
to a reception immediately following the
conclusion of this ceremony on Cross
campus which is just next door
please join us for this celebratory
occasion on behalf of all of us at Yale
congratulations
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
really
[Music]
the registers office will have my head
oh listen I am a register I gotcha
[Music]
now
thank you
sorry
[Music]